this correlate a higher place of the
bento there is up there we can see
to the houses being taken by the mud
the people being taken there
everything I built for 60 years until
of everything with a minute or two minutes
a lot of things there are people there
another olga feed father mother and already died
everything was paid to the bank
it's the companies in this machine people blame
heh heh
I believe the government is to blame too.
the staff of this machine always counted
with that bad of the dams
I always said that the dam was 100%
insurance never had escape plans or anything
because he said that he had a siren never had
that go there neither
ah